for almost two years the left has been
resisting Donald Trump yet he has
stubbornly refused to stop being this
country's democratically elected
president
unable to topple him from power by
impeachment arrest harassment or any
other means so far the left has not
given up they just become angrier by
this point totally distorted by their
rage so mad that the usual epithets have
lost their power from overuse nobody
calls Trump a sexist anymore or even a
bigot that is too kind
he's Mussolini Stalin Hitler maybe all
three of them combined plus Jeffrey
Dahmer and John Wayne Gacy no wait
that's not bad enough he is a maniacal
roman emperor who murdered his own
mother and burned his capital down that
sounds about right
Trump is literally Nero while the West
burns he's not well that's the bottom
line
that the President of the United States
is completely unhinged and getting worse
by the day the people we saw the other
evening at that rally if that's his base
it's drained what we are watching in the
Trump presidency is worse than Watergate
did you hear that worse than Watergate
says the man who hasn't worked since
Watergate yes
it is that bad the left wants Trump gone
tonight but for some unfathomable reason
he is still in the White House you can
imagine how frustrating that must be so
frustrating the progressive has shifted
the focus of their anger from the
President to the United States itself
our country they tell us must be
bulldoze to bedrock and rebuilt
according to revolutionary principles
approved by the undergraduate faculty at
Oberlin College and of course by
consensus on Twitter
step one is inviting every poor person
on planet Earth to move here tomorrow to
go on federal benefits at your expense
anything less than that is racism watch
Angela rice plain as much on CNN this
procedure is absolutely based on bigotry
and fear-mongering if you don't
understand that your president announced
his campaign by talking Moore's law to
kiss our president keeping
I never will never blame a bigot ever I
wish I could tell you we're from Africa
my ancestors came from at least part of
them but I wouldn't know because the
same bigots who are bringing who are
sending people back away from their
children are the ones who brought my
ancestors here on earth and we're in
graduation so if you listen carefully
you just learned that enforcing federal
law is now exactly the same as slavery
that's what CNN is telling us you may
not believe that but it is suddenly
orthodoxy on the left in New York State
for example Zephyr Teachout promises
that if elected Attorney General in this
fall's election she will start throwing
ice agents in prison ice has to be
abolished and I say that as somebody
who's running for one of the top law
enforcement jobs in the country and as
Attorney General I will continue to
speak out against ice I will prosecute
ice for their criminal acts in other
words those who enforce the law are the
real criminals just like illegal aliens
are the real Americans and the citizens
who work hard get married and raise
their own kids are the ones who should
be ashamed of themselves war is peace
freedom is slavery ignorance is strength
Orwell solar saw it all 70 years ago
suddenly we are living it in real time